who is David moscowage let's let's even
like because you said L Ron Hubbard
founded Scientology yeah
let's go to the story of how we
transition from that to doomscavage the
current leader of Scientology
uh he was actually not selected by Elven
Hubbard to take over but ended up
usurping power and taking over this
sounds like Stalin and Trotsky
similar story it's the it's the person
oftentimes in the situation
uh it's not the natural
successor to power it's the one that
takes power Brian I think the quote
sometimes it gets attributed to David
miscavigism power power is not given it
is assumed yeah something like that
the last six years of Alvin Hubbard's
life he was often a seclusion
essentially hiding from lawsuits now by
the time Hubbard went off into seclusion
miscavige had sort of already risen up
through the ranks of the C organization
now miscavige was like a teenager either
like 11 12 13 or something like that
Miss cabbage was not born into
Scientology but he was a young a young
boy when his father got into Scientology
okay so miscavige did start working as a
sea org member so there's one
organization that existed to essentially
serve Hubbard directly and to represent
his interest and that was called The
Commodore he was the Commodore of the
sea organization The Commodores
Messengers organization we're gonna call
it the CMO miscavige started working for
the CMO pretty early on in his sea org
career by the way as did Mike render
mini mic okay
and so he just became known as a doer
like a guy who'll get it done
no excuses no stops you know get it done
so
he had made a name for himself in the
CMO
around the time
by the time hobby went off into
seclusion now when he went off into
seclusion he took two other CMO or I'm
going to call him Messengers right
commodore's Messengers he took two other
Messengers with him patent any broker
now it has been said by people Mike Mike
rinder has told me he goes the reason
Pat and Annie went off with lrh isn't
necessarily because he desperately
wanted them to but partly because we
could afford to let them go we didn't
necessarily need them sure okay and
between the two of them Annie was the
one who was like a really compassionate
person
intelligent person caring person was
there a possible trajectory of this
world where she was the one that took
over yes in fact uh Pat and Annie broker
were the two people that were supposed
to take over okay but because Pat and
Annie were with Hubbard in seclusion
miscavige
basically had the complete run of the
operation without any oversight from
Hubbard the only way any information
would get from Scientology world to
Hubbard is miscavige and pet broker
would meet at a confidential location
and miscavige would give broker any
information he wanted to go to lrh so if
miscavige wanted to get rid of somebody
all he had to do was feed lrh false
information that this person was doing
had been caught doing something
treasonous
and then he would get in response some
order from L Ron Hubbard to get rid of
this person and so
are there so many similarities between
various communist regimes and fascist
regimes well Hitler did the same thing
when he uh became the supreme leader he
had to take power
yeah had to wait for the president to
die but the whole the whole time there's
a control of information and and a slow
aggregation of power of course with
Nations is different because if you
control the military you control a lot
so there's you have to also get the
generals on your side and so on but I'm
sure in this situation there is similar
kind of Dynamics you have to get certain
people on your side control the flow of
information
let the original founder the original
leader die off yeah and make sure that
you are the one that's left with the
power right
so whereas Pat and Annie are off with
lrh
all of scientology's attorneys and
accountants and lobbyists and whatever
they all know Dave Dave's the one they
deal with so you know lrh passes away
Pat and Annie make this appearance
nobody knows Pat Nanny everybody knows
Dave
and so he ended up getting rid of Pat
and Annie this is a very short perhaps
slightly bastardized version of it of
miscavige basically they had been they
had been um ushering just suitcases of
cash
to I'll run Hubbard during this time and
you know like so you have miscavige
handing boatloads of cash to Pat broker
Pat would do crazy things like hide the
money in the walls of houses and dig
pits and everything so miscavige
basically threatened to turn Pat broker
over to the IRS for tax evasion
that's pet broker is still alive is he a
Scientologist or no no he basically went
away
she died a handful of years ago she
stayed a loyal sea org member until the
very end
but literally like miscavige put her on
menial tasks like
like she had no Authority whatsoever she
was just put on menial tasks I mean the
washing dishes but not really
groundskeeper just just stupid low-level
assistant paper pusher stuff she never
she never operated with any actual
Authority even though she was supposed
to be the one to take over her and Pat
so on David miscavige
difficult question but can you make uh
both the case that he is a good man
who's misunderstood in the case that
he's not a good man
first of all I believe that miscavige is
a True Believer in Scientology
I do believe that that's really
important uh question do you think he
believes in all the thetans and and all
of that he definitely believes in that I
think he believes in Scientology but in
a different way than all other
scientologists because he's aware of a
lot more information yeah damaging
information about elrond Hubbard and the
true story of Scientology than most
people so his version of belief is
different I'll give you one example here
so scientology's bridge to total freedom
goes up to what they call OTAs operating
thing level eight okay
scientologists have all been told that L
Ron Hubbard before he passed finished
completed putting together
OT 910 11 12 13 14 and 15. it's just
sitting in the vault waiting to be
released this is part of the Scientology
belief system because remember I said
growing up scientology's Bridge of total
freedom is how you're supposed to get
back to your native god-like state while
all the scientologists in the world
who've already done ot8 know that they
haven't gotten there but they still
believe in Scientology because they're
told there's more but wait there's more
Miss kavich knows there is no more
so miscavige knows the fundamental
promise of being able to achieve full
operating thetan is a lie he knows L Ron
Hubbard didn't accomplish that so
therefore no one else is going to
accomplish it as well if L Ron Hubbard
had accomplished it
miscavige knows well he didn't write it
up he didn't leave instructions for how
anyone else would accomplish it so no
matter what
miscavige knows
that the fundamental promise that what
Scientology is saying they will be able
to deliver to mankind
is a lie
now it's going to sound like I'm
contradicting myself because it sounds
like I'm saying well he knows it's
[__]
I think he believes that L Ron Hubbard
just failed
to finish his work
and he's kind of hoping over on Harbor
is going to come back to finish the job
because I'll run Hubbard did tell the
people at International the
International Management base at least a
core of them that he was coming back now
we know that David miscavige believed
this because right around the 21 year
mark he was supposed to come back like
21 years after he died right around the
21 year mark David miscavige was getting
busy putting some things in place that
had to get done in case alright Hubbard
came back so we know he at least
believed to that level Because he
believes that like El Ron Hubbard can
sort of enter his own body no that's not
how it works in Scientology okay so you
can't have a transfer of
Satan's if you were full OT you could
can you uh describe the OT again so OT
levels OT one two three four five to the
eight what um what are they what's how
do you get to level one I'm gonna answer
this question by first connecting some
dots yes okay
um we spoke earlier in the interview
about achieving your native Godlike
yes state that in Scientology is called
native state
okay native state and full operating
thetent mean the exact same thing okay
because that native state you are a
fully operating thetan you know
operating meaning operating in your full
capacity
so OT means operating thing so the upper
confidential half a scientology's bridge
are called the OT levels the operating
thing levels and these and remember
they're confidential so most
scientologists have not done these
levels they don't know what's on them
it is on these levels that you learn
about the zenu and the body faten story
can you describes you know please we
spoke earlier about how at the lower
non-confidential levels of scientology's
bridge Howard is saying that what's
wrong with you is your reactive mind yes
okay
well in Scientology once you've gotten
rid of your reactive mind that is what's
called the state of clear okay so after
you finish state of clear the next thing
on the bridge is the OT levels well if
you've already gotten rid of your active
mind what the heck are you supposed to
do now well now L Ron Hubbard says Okay
first what was wrong with you was just
your reactive mind but now the next
thing you have to resolve the next thing
that's wrong with you is you actually
have tens of thousands of of thetans
stuck to your body and they all have
their own reactive Minds you have to
audit the thetans
how do you order the things are these
like different
shades of your inner mind and you have
to try to access them somehow you use
the e-meter just like we spoke about
except now you've got a divider that
separates the can so they don't short
circuit and you hold both cans in one
hand and you have the emulator in front
of you so now you're auditing yourself
you're telepathically talking to the
things that are stuck to you
you're thinking the commands instead of
saying them out loud
and you sort of do drills where you
practice looking for emitter reads at
the instant you have a thought
you're telepathically
auditing spirits that L Ron Hubbard says
are stuck to your body does this sound
like a recipe for a mental breakdown or
a heck of a mental Journey
wherever that leads it's a good lead
anywhere it'd probably lead to a very
bad place right very often does
and you combine that with the fact that
Scientology is against any forms of
mental help or health outside of
Scientology and you have a recipe for
disaster now you might go where did all
these spirits come from that are stuck
to your body this is where Xenu comes
into play so Hubbard says that 75
million years ago Xenu was basically a
dictator at the galactic Confederation
is like 70 something or 80 something
planets sit somewhere in the Milky Way
and uh Xenu was like a dictator an
Overlord for either one of these planets
or the whole system
and they had a population problem and
Xenu was like we need to get rid of like
half the people
so we called them all in for tax audits
Elder and Hubbard didn't like the IRS so
of course the story has to do with tax
audits okay called them all in for tax
audits said psych [__] froze them in
glycol loaded them up on Space planes
flew them to Earth remember the story
has to be Earth because the story is
what's wrong with us
flew them to Earth dropped them in
volcanoes blew them up with hydrogen
bombs
and then captured them with like Spirit
magnets I'm making up words because okay
um and these disembodied spirits of
these people that got blown up have just
been blown in the wind here on Earth and
they attach themselves to things and
they can be in the environment and they
stick to bodies and everything and so
and they all have reactive Minds so at
scientology's upper levels if you get
sick or you have cancer or there's
something wrong with you Scientology
will say
that's one of your body things you need
to get some auditing to fix the body
thing so this story
you do it with a kind of bit of a
chuckle but when done seriously so it's
just told in a serious way
like to like or written down you read it
by most accounts scientologists struggle
when they read this for the first time
because this is not consistent with what
scientologists are hoping for is on
their T levels they're hoping for some
real life-changing magic the way these
things are described and sold they're
remember they're hoping that these OT
levels are going to make them give them
the ability to go like completely
independent of their body at will yeah
exteriorize from your body go back into
your body you know like I have some real
Spirit Powers the first is kind of a
shock this is but then you still
probably believe you hope yeah and you
might be you might turn into on yourself
self-critical that this is I'm just not
strong enough yet
yeah because also part of the
Scientology remember it works 100 of the
time when used 100 correctly and if it
doesn't
it could be because something's not
being done right but it also could be
because
you're you're doing bad things that
you're not telling people about like if
you're committing present time over its
crimes sins
scientologists will be like that's part
of the reason auditing isn't working on
you is because you're committing
criminal behavior that you're not being
honest about so every Scientologist is
sort of incentivized to to make auditing
work on them okay now let's just work
it's a little crazy on ot3 you learn
about the OT the body things for the
first time
when you finish ot3 you attest to having
achieved this state of having no more
body things and then you start o24
and he's like psych you got more you got
more BTS except those other BTS they had
drug problems and that's why you
couldn't find them the first time so
we're gonna do a little something a
little different here do something a
little different there got to get rid of
these BTS that were addicted to drugs
okay then you finish ot4 and you're
thinking man I hope we get to the good
stuff soon and then you get to ot5 and
he's like psych you got more BTS you
couldn't find these BTS because they
were all bunched up together in clusters
and first you have to break up the
Clusters and then you can get rid of the
BTS and you're like okay gotta do that
and this was all El Ron Hubbard approved
yeah this is from L Ron Hubbard and then
after you finish ot5 you get rid of all
the BT clusters
ot6 is just a training course to teach
you how to auto ot7 well t7 is now more
BTS except it's in in the environment
and stuff you're trying to locate BTS
you can find them on your body but it's
just more BTS
okay and then ot8 is remember we talked
about in all these auditing sessions
throughout the entire Scientology Bridge
you have people who've run hundreds or
thousands of past life whole track
incidents these memories have become
part of their self-identity of who they
even think they are
ot8 you go through all these past life
recalls and essentially I'm
oversimplifying this a little bit he
goes psych all those past life memories
weren't yours
they were your BTS
and he goes now that you've discovered
this now you know who you are not
and you are ready to find out who you
really are
well now you're supposed to find out who
you really are on ot9 and 10. those
don't exist
do we know they don't exist yes in fact
the whole story of how that became known
is part of how David miscavige was able
to get rid of Pat broker and take over
power because it was believed that Pat
broker had was in possession of the
upper unreleased OT levels and when
miscavige determined that he was not and
there weren't in fact any levels
that was bad that was a bad day to be
David miscavige because he now knew he
had something on his hands he could not
get himself out of he's like so there's
no Gap
for Faith to seep in that there is
um a level 9 and 10 11 and 12. oh the
faith is there scientologists believe
that these things do exist yeah
alright Hubbard didn't leave anything
behind does David miscavige believe they
exist oh no he knows he knows they don't
exist no meaning when I say exist oh I
don't mean do Advanced
um uh levels of spiritual awareness
exist when I said is it means did L Ron
Hubbard write down what anyone is
supposed to do that's called ot9 that
doesn't exist so you're seeing David
miscarriage believes that they can be
written down so they exist sort of in
the platonic sense
and El Ron Hubbard is the only one that
can write it down so his face is really
deep Oh you mean his faith that only El
Ron Hubbard could have ever been the one
to do it yeah the full principles
beliefs of uh Scientology he is
do you have
are you sure he believes that what
exactly
everything about scientologies that is
true to the best of my ability to know
that I believe it to be true
like I'll give you small even stupid
examples like Mike renders told a story
where at the international base
miscavige actually had like a copper a
Contraption built into the ground like
grounded in the ground to come out where
you could hold it and if something he
sort of came up with to uh your BT it
could ground your BTS could get your BTS
that if you were feeling overstimulated
or something I'm probably slightly
bastardizing this story but he came up
with this as a great idea something to
help someone destimulate if their BTS
were getting a little too overactive
used now so that that's a stupid story
that's sort of like well it shows you he
believes in the concept of BTS if he's
creating little rods to get rid of them
to ground them into the Earth well he
could be Conjuring up the stories
because uh he understands the power of
myth and narrative and so on to uh to
inspire sure but like but also if we
look at history both with um this
interesting thing because I've been
reading a lot about Hitler and Stalin
and it seems like both of them in
different ways
believed
in uh the stories they were telling even
when the stories this is the fascinating
especially with Hitler and propaganda
where they were literally conjured up at
first but then you start to believe
you're on propaganda
uh with Stalin I think what he always
believed is the bigger idea of pure
communism and anything justifies the
journey to communism because it will
ultimately be good for Humanity to
achieve the state of pure communism and
then he's a god-like figure that can can
bring uh can bring Humanity there but
like well Hitler it's interesting
because like this constant propaganda
that he knows is not true
a little bit there's got to be doubt but
then he like that all doubt is removed
very quickly yeah so I guess humans are
just this is how they operate yeah the
conversation about David miscavis gets
really interesting because I could give
you a if I wanted to make the argument
that he didn't believe I could give you
a dozen examples to to make that
argument I just happen
to think that uh he believes in a
different way whereas your average
Scientologist believes that Alvernon
Hubbard was practically infallible that
he thought of everything in advance he
took care of everything before he left
and miscavige still believes in like the
main structure of this thing but he's
like oh [__] it's falling to me to
figure out how to actually make this
thing happen I I think Miss gavige sees
himself as someone who has to a certain
degree had to go back and fix I'll run
Hubbard's mistakes do you think he sees
himself as doing good for the world I do
what about for the people of Scientology
I think in his own way he does
I don't think he wakes up thinking he's
um screwing scientologists
I think he sees everyone else as
screwing him
I think he sees uh that he that it is
his job to expand Scientology throughout
the world and accomplish the aims of
Scientology and he sees that it's not
happening and he thinks if everyone else
would just stop if everyone else would
get out of his way and stop creating
problems for him it would happen like uh
I I do think he seems to sees himself as
someone who is doing good I think that's
fair to say
I think the evidence shows that what
about the effects of clearly power and
influence that he's had and money yeah
without question that has served as a
corrupting force it has without question
have you seen sort of evidence of that
that he's changed over time after the
1993 IRS exemption that Scientology won
back
um and this information comes from Mike
rinder
uh that's when David miscavige as soon
as the checks on his power were removed
miscavige's Behavior changed markedly